>> I think we begin at November 16th, 1906, right?
Okay. The difference between the offenses of the religious
and those of the secular meaning the laity, but that the term secular
for Louisa doesn't just include the laity as we know it meaning members
of the church, but everybody out there who's not actually part
of the church, so all the unbelievers and everything.
The term secular is used in a different sense nowadays
because it literally means without God, okay?
And Louisa said as I was in my usual state I saw the many offenses committed
by priests and by religious people and the great sorrow that blessed Jesus felt
because of them.
Almost surprised I said my sweet life, it's true that religious people offend you,
but it seems to me that the laity or the secular offend you more.
Yet you know you show greater sorrow for the first than the second.
It seems you're all eyes to look at what the first are doing
and you seem not to look about the second are doing.
Now before we even move on, the people who hurt you the most are
not the ones living on the next street, they're the ones who are living
in your house and the reason is they are the ones who are closest to you,
they're the ones who are committed to you, okay?
And that's the logic of what Jesus is saying.
He said, "Am I daughter, you cannot understand the difference that exists
between the offenses of the religious and those of the laity."
That is why you are surprised.
The religious have declared that they belong to me.
That means they've taken vows, okay?
And that they love me and that they serve me.
And I have entrusted the treasures of my grace to them.
So they're in charge of the church and it's mission.
And I've given them the treasures of this, I've given the treasures of the sacraments
to others who are the priests.
Now while pretending on the outside, what is the word for that hypocrisy?
Is that one thing Jesus really, really condemned?
While pretending on the outside that they belong to me in their interior,
if they need, they are far from me.
Now that's literally Matthew 15 verses 1 to 10, Matthew 15 verses 1 to 10.
These people honor me with lip service but their hearts are far from me.
Also Sam 5 verses 5 to 6, Sam 5 verses 5 to 6.
They show that they love me and serve me but they offend me and they use holy things
to serve their own passions.
That is a very specific insult to the Lord.
Inside that I want you to have a cook 1.13, H-A-B-B is have a cook.
Have a cook 1.13.
Lord your eyes are too holy to look upon sin, that's what that says.
This is why I am all eyes so as not to let them spoil my gifts and my graces but in spite
of my cares they reach the point of wrecking havoc with those very things with which on
the outside they seem to be glorifying me.
That was precisely the problem that Jesus had with the scribes and Pharisees.
This offense is so grave that if you could understand it you would die of heartbreak.
On the other hand the secular or the laity that they don't belong to me and they don't
know me.
Now very particularly those who are outside the church and that they don't want to serve
me and because of this first of all they are free of the spirit of hypocrisy which
is what the problem of the others which is the thing that displeases me the most.
So put beside that Matthew 23 where Jesus gave a terrible indictment to the scribes
and Pharisees because of hypocrisy.
Therefore since they have declared themselves I have not been able to entrust my gifts to
them even though grace excites them it fights them it has not given itself because they
don't want it.
It happens we would say it's the same as if a king who having waged battle to free the
people from the slavery in which they were kept by other kings they managed by force
of blood to free some of those people and then he placed them under his dominion providing
everything for them and if necessary letting them live in his own residence.
That's the position of the priests and religious.
Now who would displease him more if they offended him?
The peoples which have remained far away from him and which he yet wanted to free are the
ones that actually live with him that's the problem of the elder brother in Luke 15.
So if you put Luke 15 because the elder brother was actually still staying in the father's
house and yet he sinned greatly against the father and yet you would get the impression
from the story that the real sinner was the younger one when the story is finished you're
not so sure about that are you okay.
So November 18th 1906 and the heading is very important the works without interior spirit
and upright intention bloat the soul doesn't make it grow now bloating isn't a wonderful
feeling as you know as I was in my usual state I saw only a shadow of blessed Jesus and he
told me my daughter if a food could be separated from his substance and someone else ate it
it would be of no use or rather it would serve only to bloat his stomach in other words you
get no value out of it.
Such are the works without interior spirit and without upright intention being emptied
of divine substance they are of no use and they serve only to bloat the person now in
spiritual language that is pride they serve only to make you proud therefore he receives
more harm than good therefore things are not what they seem is what you're being told aren't
you things are not what they seem so a person can have the right clothes they can have the
right job they can be in the right place they can be doing the right actions and they may
not be serving God at all and somebody else who doesn't appear to be serving God at all
might be loving and kind and forgiving it's it's amazing so November the 20th 1906 obedience
communicates divine strength to the soul now you had an underlying divine.
My poor state continues Louisa says full of bitterness because of the almost continuous
privations that I suffer but also of peace that's very important that she adds that she
has all this pain but she has this peace in her soul you see without that peace you're
not really in the divine will the peace that passes all understanding is Philippians 4
8 Philippians 4 7 sorry Philippians 4 7 I saw him just flashing by telling me my daughter
obedience is an unshakable wall and such it renders the soul that Sam 18 verses 2 and 31
not only strong and robust and obedience communicates divine strength in such a way
that in the face of the divine strength that it possesses all things are weak so I want
to give you Sam 27 verse 5 Sam 27 verse 5 and Sam 62 verse 2 so much so that while obedience
can move everything nothing can move it now you can see why Jesus has absolutely insisted
that Louisa's entire life be based on obedience because he is going to he is doing such an
incredible work in her that if she wasn't on this absolutely solid foundation she could
easily go astray and the whole church will be depending on this revelation as the revelation
breaks out further and further into the church.
So November the 28th 1906 I have a VIP on it and it's about Jesus returning to the earth
to live in and through souls in the divine will so it's an explanation of how the return
of Jesus to the earth is going to come now there are evangelicals and people like that
are absolutely certain he's going to come back in the flesh he's going to live in an
actual city called the new Jerusalem and it is going to fall down out of heaven by some
unknown means and that Jesus is going to actually reign on the earth for a thousand years all
physical okay and even though they claim that they understand the scriptures better than
Catholics because they take such a fundamentalist approach to it they actually distort it and
one of the most basic things that you will come across in scripture is God never repeats
himself he's a creator and that's number one and number two not only does he never repeat
himself the only thing he enjoys doing is creating apart from loving so if you can create and
you get an opportunity to create would you patch did Jesus say he would patch they said
no no way would you put a patch on a cloth the cloth was Judaism is it no way no way would
I put new wine into old wineskins he does something completely new but the second thing
that the scriptures make perfectly clear is that he manages to fulfill all his promises
and still surprise everybody in the way he doesn't now only the few people who are in
the divine will know the way he's coming back all the others are writing books about all
that they're all wrong and if they knew what we knew about the return of Christ they wouldn't
believe us at all that he would return in simple ordinary people do you know what I mean what
if they examined the gospel they would realize he always went to the poor the lame the blind
the lepers the marginalized the people that other people thought were important and sinners
they're all sinners but he always went to the people that nobody thought you should
give any attention to so he's come to us as well I think it's brilliant but it's only
only the humble are going to get it and the Sam say that only the humble will hear and
be glad so this is a very important message continuing in my poor state I just barely
saw blessed Jesus who seemed to transform all of himself into me see how deep the divine
will goes you and me and I in you that's John 14 21 John 14 21 if I moved one arm I could
feel him move his arm within me so what she's trying to illustrate here is that this read
this is a genuine reality this isn't some mystical grace that you have to imagine in
your mind okay and so with all the rest if she moved a foot she could feel his while
he was doing this he told me my beloved daughter oh sorry you need to know the language that
we use for this and that is he bi locates himself in us okay just to make sure you write
it down he bi locates himself in us and she doesn't know a big word called bi location
okay so she she describes the thing that it's real so he said my beloved daughter see in
what close union I am with you this is how I want you to be completely united and clasped
to me we would say two metals soldered together okay and and do not think that you must do
this only when you suffer or pray but rather always always if you move if you breathe if
you work if you eat if you sleep everything everything as if you were doing it in my humanity
and as if you're working came from me in such a way that you should be nothing but the cortex
and once the cortex of your work is broken one would find the fruit of the divine work
so there you have the cortex of the tree and all the life is inside okay and all the
work that that tree is doing is on the inside and you can use it but don't keep you can
use it but it's just making noise on that okay so you have the cortex of the tree and
then you have all the activity of the tree is inside and all the fruitfulness then is
appears appears in the external parts of it so the outer layer is Louisa and the inner
activity is the divine will you have a very good description there of a living host haven't
you just want to give you the crossover a living host the the accidents are on the outside
and the divine presence is on the inside okay as the source of life and so everything is
to be done for the Lord so beside that I want you to do Ephesians 210 we are God's work
of art created in Christ Jesus okay so everything you're you're to do it as if you were doing
it in my humanity and as if your working came from me in such a way that you would be nothing
but the cortex and once the cortex of your work is broken in death that's understood you
would find the fruit of a divine work this is the revelation of the divine will operating
and living in us and this you must do for the good of the whole of humanity that's one
of the signs of a person in the divine will they are concerned with all souls past present
and future not just with one or two in such a way that my humanity must be present as
though alive in the midst of people so you can see that this is his way to be present
and active in the midst of the society around so this is like another incarnation and just
put it the word incarnation in inverted commas because incarnation means in a body is that
okay and this is his way to come back and live with us in fact as you do everything even
the most indifferent actions with this intention of receiving life from me your action acquires
the merit of my humanity look at that because it's Jesus acting living and acting in us
so our actions then acquire the merits of his humanity because since I was man and God
in my breathing I contained the breathing of all in his movements in his actions in his
thoughts he contained the movements and actions and thoughts of everything within himself
therefore I sanctified them I divinized them I repaired them so by doing everything in
the act of receiving all of your working from me you too will come to embrace and contain
all creatures within you now we're still at the stage of being very anxious to pray for
individuals okay but he's telling you that if you actually understand operating in the
divine will you have them all inside of you every one of them past present and future
every one of them you're praying for them all but it's just hard for us to take it on
board when we're so used to praying for individuals and so you too will come to embrace and contain
all creatures within you and your working will diffuse for the good of all all is PPF past
present and future therefore even if the others will give me nothing I will take everything
from you so our operating means that the glory and praise and thanksgiving and reparation
that are required and are due to the Lord will actually be given to him on behalf of
everyone so Louisa said I think I'm talking nonsense she uses that expression to say
I'm not sure if I got through it here and these are intimate things and I'm unable to
say them well I would like to write them as I have them in my mind but I cannot that's
typical of someone who has received information in and out of the body experience when they
come back into the the body they just don't have the words it seems that I take one drop
of light and one hundred more escape me it would have been better if I had kept silent
but after all everything is for the glory of God so December the third 1906 the sweetness
and the peace of the soul now one of the things that Louisa points out very clearly in the
passion of Jesus is the sweetness that he showed to all the people that were torturing him no
matter how terrible they were treating him he had this extraordinary peaceful and sweet
expression for the mole to the point where they had to blindfold him they couldn't take
looking at him since blessed Jesus was not coming I felt such bitterness Louisa says not
only this but a sort of hitch within my interior such as to make me almost restless she said
what pain all other pains compared to this are nothing but shadows or rather refreshment
your privation alone can be given the name of pain okay so I've explained to you before
that both purgatory and hell the pain is the absence of God and purgatory is not as bad
as hell because someday you will have him okay now while I was visiting he came out in
passing from within my interior and he said to me what is the matter with you can yourself
can yourself here I am not only with you but within you okay and then it's okay I do not
want this restless heart okay so I want you to write Sam 62 verses one to two and verses
five to eight rest in God my soul I know I feel like a tumbling wall and a tottering
fence but rest in God my soul okay everything in you must be sweetness and peace in such
a way that it may be said of you that which was said of me that nothing but milk and honey
flows from me now there you have got a major and answer to a major question in the Old Testament
and the major question someone's mobile phone is on can you turn it off you can hear it
will you turn off all mobile phones please and the Old Testament question is why was the
land of Canaan called the land of milk and honey anybody who has ever been there knows
that milk and honey don't flow around the place okay so everybody's all further now
you know that it's called the land of milk and honey because they were having this very
special relationship with God okay so it's a major answer to a question that theologians
and scripture scholars have battled with all down the centuries so you can say that
you know the answer oh sorry turn it off the left button turn it off so he said nothing
but milk and honey flows from me symbolizing sweetness and honey piece from milk okay I am
so filled and soaked with them that they pour out from my eyes from my mouth and from all
my works and if you are not like if you are not likewise I feel dishonored by you because
while the one who is all peace and sweetness dwells within you you do not honor me by showing
even the slightest you do not honor me if you show even the slightest shadow of a resentful
and restless heart okay that's a very important statement he says in the divine will we have
this very special relationship with God and it's to lead us to a new and divine holiness
not a human holiness but a divine holiness so he says in us if there's even a shadow
of resentment that is a huge huge huge thing so I want to give you a few scriptures on that
on Samuel 230 and a very big one in sirek or ecclesiastical s-i-r is sirek chapter 27
from verse 30 to chapter 28 verse 9 and in the book of sirek you're told that resentment
is a foul thing and it is found with sinners hence you're going to find there's no tolerance
for it at all in divine will is that okay book of sirek chapter 27 from verse 30 to
chapter 28 verse 9 so he doesn't want either even a shadow of a resentful or a restless
heart now the restlessness thing he has talked about it from volume 1 to 4 non-stop he kept
on saying to her if you are restless if you are not at peace within then you can be attacked
by temptations by human beings by demons by everything but you won't get through to God
God needs this peace inside of you because this piece is a union with God in total trust
okay and so he says very clearly I love this sweetness and peace so much that even if it
were about something great concerning my honor and glory I do not want I never approve resentful
violent fiery manners I don't know how many of us that knocks out but you know it hits
hard but he has the very clear words I do not want that that couldn't be clearer could
it but I want rather sweet and peaceful manners that's your Philippians four seven the peace
that passes all understanding okay in fact sweetness alone is that which binds hearts
like a chain in such a way that they cannot unbind themselves now he's saying that this
sweet gentle manner draws people to God more than anything else it is like pitch that sticks
to them and they cannot free themselves and they're forced to say in this soul there is
the finger of God now there's Jesus himself using the language of the magicians back in
Exodus chapter eight verse nineteen this is the finger of God and you also have a reference
to that in Luke 11 20 so Exodus 8 19 and Luke 11 20 and if you look at me for a moment I'll
illustrate it the finger of God is always illustrated this way that it's the the four
finger of the right hand with the other fingers down and the tongue that way and it's a sign
of authority and so when people in the Old Testament said that's the finger of God's right
hand obviously they're emperors and caesars and pharaohs and that use that as a sign of
their authority okay and so that means that God is actually present with his authority
okay in this soul there is the finger of God and we cannot act otherwise and then if I do
not like a resentful manner not even creatures like it which is actually true isn't it you
see we've been made like God and the things we don't like in other people God doesn't
like in us either okay if one speaks about or deals with things even of God with manners
that are not sweet and peaceful it's a sign that he does not have his passions in order
my goodness what would you have said about when we were young and the regemptors were
thumping the altar shouting that God would send us to hell for even being late for mass
for two minutes let me really think of that and they thought they were putting the fear
of God in us I don't think they succeeded did they it means that he does not have these
passions in order and one who does not keep himself in order cannot order others you can
only give what you have therefore be careful with anything which is not sweetness and peace
if you do not want to dishonor me so I'm going to give you a few scriptures on that one okay
to look it up the book of Judges chapter 14 and verse 14 book of Judges 14 14 Sam 119 103
Philippians 4 18 and 2 Corinthians 2 15 so that's Judges 14 14 Philippians 4 18 2 Corinthians
2 15 and Sam 119 verse 103 so December the 6th 1906 Jesus hides to see what the soul will
do and this is a very very simple incident but it's actually more important than you
think continuing my state of almost total privation at the most he comes like a flash
or a shadow I was saying in my interior life of my life how is it that you're not coming
oh how cruel you have become to me how hard your heart has become as you reach the point
of not listening to me where are your promises where is your love since you leave me abandoned
in the abyss of miseries yet you promised me that you would never leave me Joshua 1 5
you told me that you love me and now and now she said you yourself told me that it is
from one's constancy that it can be known whether one really loves you that's the reference
to the very first thing in this volume and if there is no constancy one it cannot rely
on this love so how is it that you want it from me who does not form your life and then
you who are my life denier to me shouldn't let him off with much does she but who can
say all of my nonsense she said I would be too long in the meantime he moved in my interior
is there all the time raising his arm in the act of sustaining me and he says I am within
you Luke 17 21 and I hide more in you to see what you will do I have failed in nothing
neither in promises nor in love nor in constancy if you imperfect do it I do it in the fullness
of perfection towards you now she doesn't go on with explaining this she was probably
too shocked but the Lord is saying sometimes your people say well I prayed and I did all
the right things and I did my fasting and all the rest but and he didn't answer me I
didn't get the result I wanted and we do not take into account that the Lord wants your
growth more than anything else he wants you to grow in union with him more than anything
else and very often he does what is generally called the cliffhanger move have you heard
the cliffhanger move before the cliffhanger move is that he waits until you're hanging
over the cliff and the next breath you're gone and you're dead and he wants to see will
you trust him up to up to and including the last breath and if you trust him beyond reason
because you've heard me tell you before that he has told me to tell everyone to trust him
beyond reason if you trust him beyond reason and you are hanging over the clip onto a branch
I know this I've been there done that and got the t-shirt and we say Lord when the branch
goes then the zone you left okay then he moves because what you've done is you've passed
the test of trust let me illustrate it for you and this is a story that I didn't make
up and it's the story of a man who was able to ride a bicycle on a rope across the Niagara
Falls and he had a crowd you've heard the story before there was a crowd on either side and
of course they gave him a huge roar of a plot when he arrived on the other side so he got
off his bike and he said so I can do it can't I and they said yes he said someone get up
on the back and come with me and out of a crowd of thousands of people not one offered
to join him and that's the way Jesus says he says you know I can walk on water you know
that I've actually done it how about following me because to be walking on water means that
you are walking in total trust you're just trusting him you're not looking at the circumstances
around you you're just saying I'm keeping my eyes on you and that's it I'm just trusting
and people will agree with it on paper and they'll clap anybody who does it but let them
step out and do it it's a different matter you know you can put it a mat down on this
floor and say would you walk on it you said of course I'll walk on it's no problem but
the same matter over a gorge with a 300 foot drop will you walk on it no way it's a different
matter altogether because the second time there's no floor underneath and so the first
time is not a test the second time is so Jesus said to Louisa I hold back to see what you
will do now we've seen a couple of times that she responded magnificently I love her this
up for everybody and one stage and I'll offer it up to prove my love for you and here she's
back complaining our usual stunt she's terribly like us isn't she that we do fine and we can
really make it at one stage and then we're right back to the old stuff again and just
one of the things I actually love about her if she was less humble she would have left
out the bits that enables us to grow okay so December the 15th 1906 how the divine will
contains all goods and you need to sort of underline the all bit continuing in my usual
state I was feeling embittered more than ever because of his privation in one moment I felt
as though absorbed in the will of God and I felt all my interior appeased now to have
that everything inside of her brought to this total can she had to be absorbed into the
divine will in such a way as to no longer feel myself now what she's talking about there
is she's not feeling her body at all she's not feeling anything inside of her body I only
feel the divine will in everything even in his privation now that's a major major major
statement on Louis's part a major step forward this is going to be her reality as she goes
on I myself said to myself what strength what enchantment what magnet the divine will contains
such as to make me forget all about myself and make the divine volition flow in everything
that's what the Lord wants from us all and you need to sort of put a some kind of a sign
there and put a big end be beside it that's what he's asking from for us all at that moment
he moved in my interior and told me my daughter since the divine will is the only nourishing
food that contains all flavors and tastes together now the expression of flavors and
tastes he says the only thing that genuinely satisfies you body soul mind and spirit okay
all tastes that are suitable for the soul the soul finds her favorite food and becomes
appeased her desire finds its food and it only thinks of pastoring itself slowly no rush
and it forms without desiring anything else or inclination has nothing else towards which
to tend because it has found the food that satisfies it her will has nothing else to
look for because the soul has left her own will which formed her torment and is found
the divine will instead which forms her happiness she's left her poverty and is found wealth
not human wealth divine wealth in some all of the interior of the soul find its food that
is it's crafting with which it remains so occupied and absorbed as to be unable to move
any further in fact while finding all contentment in this food and crafting the soul finds so
much to do and to learn and ever new things to enjoy and from a minor knowledge she learns
major knowledge and there is always something else to learn in other words in the divine
will you are shifted out of your university and into a divine university out of your human
university into a divine one and of course Louisa has already said to us that you would
learn more in a half an hour or in ten minutes than you would in years in a university she
passes from small things to great things from one taste she moves to other tastes and there's
always something new to taste in this environment of the divine will very important statement
all of that wonderful stuff and so to put that into a kind of a sentence you'd say because
I did challenge you in your study groups to take something like that and make a point okay
so if we're making a point it is that in the divine will everything that the human being
desires is satisfied so January the 3rd 1907 true trust reproduces divine life in the soul
now notice the word true in front of trust continuing in my usual state I saw blessed
Jesus for just a little and he told me my daughter if one fears much it is a sign that
the soul relies on herself one John four eighteen because in noticing nothing but weaknesses
and miseries within herself she naturally and justly fears in other words if you're concentrating
on the cracks you'll be afraid to do anything on the other hand if one fears nothing it is
a sign that she relies on God there's the bicycle going across the rope on the Niagara
Falls okay if she fears nothing it's a sign that she relies on God because in relying
on God her miseries and weaknesses are dissolved in God look at that dissolved did you notice
and as she feels invested by the divine being look at that language it is no longer she
who operates but God operating within her so what has she to fear a Sam 27 one what have
you to fear the Lord is my light and my help therefore true trust reproduces divine life
in the soul I want to give you a few scriptures now I want to give you one Timothy four ten
one Timothy four ten one Peter three five Ephesians one twelve Jeremiah seventeen seven
and Galatians two twenty I no longer live Christ lives in me now notice the miseries and
the weaknesses dissolved in God because of the way we were reared and trained and taught
and all the rest of it and not reared and not trained and not taught okay we are inclined
to think of our miseries and our weaknesses and our disadvantages and all the rest of it
and if you think of them too much you actually can't go forward which isn't actually possible
to go forward and so the Lord says look will you trust me and just throw yourself into the
divine arms and forget about the problems is that okay is everybody comfortable or too
hot or anything okay so January the fifth 1907 I have a VIP on this one true sanctity
consists of receiving anything that may happen to us as a specialty of divine love we're going
to love this one particularly during the week okay so let me repeat this again this is this
is for operating on during the week true sanctity consists of receiving anything that may happen
to us as a specialty of divine love there's something happening to me at the moment and
I'm not tempted to see it as a specialty of divine love saying okay I surrender and all
the rest of it but looking at it as a specialty of divine love you see the challenge okay having
read about a soul who had scruples about everything and who feared that everything might be seen
I was thinking to myself how lact I am I too would like to think of everything maybe sin
so as to be more attentive not to offend the Lord and when Jesus came he told me my daughter
this is nonsense putting all your attention on these nothings you know and it turns you
completely into yourself and the soul remains stuck on the path of sanctity while true and
solid sanctity consists of receiving anything which may happen to her or which she may be
doing be it even the most indifferent thing as a specialty of divine love I would think
that would transform us rather quickly but if you pass your test first go would you let
me know just as it would be if she found a food enjoyable or disgusting and watch this
you're going to get a couple of examples of specialities okay a specialty of love in the
enjoyment thinking that it is Jesus that produces that enjoyment in the food and that he loves
her to the point of giving her pleasure even in material things okay number two lent is coming
a speciality of love in the disgust thinking that he loves her so much is to produce that
disgust for her in order to make her similar to himself and mortification giving her himself a
little coin that she can offer to him now there's the divine currency and more and more you're
going to hear about the divine currency that things that cost you a little can be used as
divine currency to get souls thirdly a speciality of divine love if she's humiliated if she is
exalted if she's healthy if she's in firm whether she's poor or rich a speciality of love her breathing
her sight her speech everything everything and just as she must receive everything everything is
a speciality of divine love she must give everything back to God as a special love of hers now it's
one thing to receive it as a speciality of divine loves quite another matter to turn around and
offer it to him as a speciality of love coming from you with gratitude and all the rest of
so she must receive the wave of the love of God and she must give to God the wave of her love
or what a sanctifying bath is this wave of love it purifies her it sanctifies her it makes her
advance without her even realizing it like that's lovely isn't it it is a life more of heaven than
of earth and this is what I want from you sin and the thought of sin mustn't even exist for you
because you see that belongs to back there it doesn't belong to now in the divine will and
it most certainly doesn't belong in the future so that's one John three two one John three two
those who are truly in union with God do not sin okay
so January the 10th I have a VIP on this one and it says the evil of one's own taste now
instead of the word taste would you write beside it you don't knock it out or anything but right
beside it satisfaction your own satisfaction and put a little stroke whims and another little stroke
once so instead of taste the evil of one's own taste satisfaction whims and once then you have it
the translator likes the word taste so he uses it quite frequently but then of course if he's
Italian I don't understand that and as I was in my usual state blessed Jesus came for just a little
and he told me my daughter the attachment of people to their own satisfactions whims preferences
tastes once do you see that I where I'm trying to elaborate on it for you is such that I'm forced
to contain my gifts within myself in fact instead of becoming attached to the donor that's himself
they become attached to my gifts idolatizing my gifts to the offense of the donor let me give you
an example of this because we've had some of this problem we've had a lot of it in America and some
of it in Ireland as well there've been some famous people in America in the last century who became
absolutely famous as healers okay now if they presented themselves to everybody as I am the great
healer zero out of a hundred the gift belongs to the lord they were just the people the lord was
actually using and if they presented themselves as the healers then it meant that they were using
it for their own benefit for their own glory their own mother it's exactly the same if a gift of
teaching has been given and you present yourself as the great teacher you've missed the boss the
train the airplane everything you see that you can use the gift wrongly and it can end up no use
to you or anybody else is that okay and whereas in the divine will all the time we realize it is the
lord who's playing the children now I don't know if you remember the days when we watch Tom and Jerry
you might be too sophisticated or too old or too some but I'm not and I've always loved Tom and Jerry
as the most perfect parable of the relationship between the clergy and the laity it's absolutely
perfect perfect I remember telling that to a bishop and he looked at me and I said you don't watch Tom
and Jerry do you I said you need to you'll learn a lot about the church and anyway so Tom is pretending
to be a great pianist or whatever it is you know and he has got this magnificent piano forte you
know and he's got the audience out the audience are all clapping and everything and he bows and he
takes it all and all the rest of it next thing the lid comes up and Jerry is inside and Jerry was
doing all that so one person is taking all the glory and the other one's doing all the work
perfect image of the church the laity do an awful lot of work that other people take glory for
do you know what I mean but that's only a humorous side to it you know what I mean but it's it's to
keep our eyes on the donor and what he wants to do and what he wants to accomplish and to keep
ourselves in our native nothingness is absolutely fantastic that means then that some gift that
God has given to you won't actually destroy you so they become attached to their gifts a dollar
tracing my gifts to the offense of the donor so if they find their own satisfaction I think is a
very good word they act or rather they do not just to satisfy their own wants or whatever it is in
other words the problem is self indulgence okay and if there's no satisfaction in it they don't
want to do it so they're not actually serving God they're just serving themselves so one's own taste
or satisfaction forms a second life in many people but miserable ones they do not know that where
there is your own satisfaction present the divine taste can hardly be there even in very holy
things now notice very holy things so in receiving my gifts graces and favors the soul must not
appropriate them as her own things making of them a satisfaction for herself she must keep them as
divine gifts using them in order to love the Lord more and be ready to sacrifice them to that very
love so there's the problem of self-indulgence in holy things a very simple example of self-indulgence
and holy things found frequently in people who are starting out an ordinary spiritual life now not
divine will and they're getting into a prayer life and they will pray for hours and hours and hours
when they're enjoying the prayer and when they come into aridity and prayer they won't say a solitary
word and so they have to be helped by a spiritual director to know that you don't indulge just
because you're enjoying it and you don't pull back just because it's difficult in actual fact it's
in the times of aridity that you really grow you know and that's that's just a classic example
of how people experience prayer so I have a VIP on January the 13th 1907 as well
Jesus wanted to suffer in his humanity in order to redo human nature so we've heard about Jesus
redoing the human nature continuing in my usual state I saw my blessed Jesus flashing by and he
told me my daughter how much I love souls listen human nature was corrupted humiliated without hope
of glory or of resurgence and I wanted to suffer all humiliations in my humanity that's Isaiah 52
14 Isaiah 52 14 in a special way I wanted to be stripped scourged and let my flesh fall off in
shreds under the scourges almost on doing my humanity in order to redo the humanity of the
human race and to make it rise again full of life of honor and glory to eternal life what more could
I do that I have not done so that's the same kind of thinking that you find in the reproaches on good
Friday what more could I have done for you okay and I often think that on judgment day for the
souls who chose to go to hell that he will show them everything he did that actually paid for
their salvation and say was that not enough that would be a worse judgment than just simply
saying depart from me because they would see what they had actually rejected and so January the 20th
1907 I also have a VIP on that one the greatest sanctity is to live in the divine will having read
the lives of two female saints one who aspired very much to suffering and the other who aspired
so much to be little now when you consider this is 207 who would be the one who would desire to
be so very little saint to raise who would be the one who would desire very much to suffer
I know he's later this 1907 no no no she's she's reading the lives of two female saints
Gemma Galgani you think of someone in the time before her this is 1907 you got to think of people
in the time before her and and there are others of course but they're the two I remember
and I was thinking in my interior about which of the two would be better to imitate and unable to
make up my mind I felt as though hampered so in order to be free and to think only about loving
Jesus I said to myself I want to aspire to nothing but to love Jesus and to fulfill his holy will
perfectly well that was Saint Therese's motto that was actually Saint Therese's motto at that time the
Lord told me in my interior and it is here that I want you in my will not anywhere else until the
grain of wheat is buried in the earth and dies completely he's quoting John's gospel chapter 12
verse 24 John 12 24 until the grain of wheat is buried in the earth and dies completely it cannot
rise again to new life and multiply itself giving life to other grains in the same way until the
soul is buried in my will now notice the word buried that means it's over done and dusted to the
point of dying completely by dissolving all of herself within me she cannot rise again to new
life through the rising of all the virtues of Christ that contain through sanctity now what you're
being told here is that a genuine death to self has got to happen for the divine will to truly
triumph in us a genuine death to self has got to happen and so I want to give you a revelation
seven verses two to four and okay revelation seven verses two to four therefore let my will be the
seal that's revelation nine four let my will be the seal which seals your interior and exterior
and once my will has risen completely within you you will find true love this is the greatest of
all the other this is the greatest of all the other sanctities to which one can aspire
in other words the thirty six volumes are summarized in divine will and divine love
so as we're moving more and more into the divine will we have to be moving more and more into
divine love as well so I want to give you a few references for that this is for the love
Deuteronomy six verses four to five Deuteronomy six verses four to five John 13 verses 34 and 35
and one John four seven God is love okay now notice he's asking us to let the movement
of our being go into real genuine death to self so that divine love can be born now all the saints
have said that before louisa they just didn't know about the divine part of the sanctity they said
that the the ego must die for for agape love that's the divine love to be born in us okay so
January the 21st 1907 one who always loves Jesus cannot displease him look at that
here you're dealing with the all-powerfulness of love finding myself in my usual state
I was saying in my interior Lord let it be that I may be all yours and that I may be always always
with you and that I may never separate from you however while I am with you do not permit that I
may be a goat that embitters you that I may bother you that I may displease you but that I may be a
goat that is present in you to sustain you when you are tired or oppressed that consoles you
when you are bothered by other creatures while I was saying this to blessed blessed Jesus told me
my daughter one who is in continuous attitude of loving me is always with me that's a VIP bit
and this person can never be a goat that gives me bother but a goat that sustains me relieves me
and soothes me in fact true love has this as its own thing it renders the beloved content
besides one who always loves me can never displease me because love absorbs the entire person
that's why this spirituality of divine love is it its perfection at the most there might be little
things and the soul herself does not even realize that she may displease me but love itself takes on
the commitment to purifier so that I may always find my delights in her now you know that the church
teaches that when you receive Holy Communion correctly and reverently that the Lord deals with small
faults he does the brushing down and you know he just deals with small things and so that's not
what bothers him what bothers him is when we set our will against something we put our will into
something or that we put our self forward if we're glorifying the self and we put the will they're
the two biggies they're the two baddies you know beyond that he doesn't mind and would you bother
for example if a child came in from playing outside and they got their dress or their trousers dirty
but they came in and gave you the biggest hug you ever got in your life would it bother you no
would you worry about the dress or the trousers you would not you wouldn't even think about it
that's what he's saying as well that the the love takes precedence okay so John that sorry John the
21st January the 21st 1907 one who always loves Jesus cannot displease him oh yeah we're doing
that aren't we okay so yeah so we go to January the 25th where Louisa sees chastisements okay
I'm going through the most bitter days because of the almost continuous privations of blessed
Jesus at the most he makes himself seen in passing and like a flash and immediately he hides so
very deep within my interior that I can't even catch sight of him and always in silence now she
she must know at this stage that he's chastising even we know it so when I saw him after much
struggling and he was all in bitter dendot press I said to him tell me at least what is it that
makes you you suffer so much and he unwilling but only to content me told me and my daughter you do
not know what must happen I think that is world war one and if I told you you would break my
indignation and I would not do what I have to do this is why I keep silent so calm yourself about
the way I act with you in this period of time but courage it will be so very bitter for you
but do it as an athlete as a generous one always living but as though dead in my will
without even crying now in the early volumes Louisa used to cry easily and the lord is asking her to
grow up and to take his privation and whatever happens and to take it a bit more on the chin
and having said this he hid deeper within my interior leaving me as though petrified without
even being able to cry about his privation she's not allowed to cry now the poor guys are not allowed
to die or cry okay now to obey I write that even before the month of january until now I do nothing
but find myself outside of myself notice that I do nothing but find myself out she started the body
experience most of the time it may also be a dream but I seem to see places in desolation
cities deserted entire streets with the houses closed with no one walking among them and dead
people my fright at seeing these things is such a surrender me as though dazed and I would like
to imitate my good Jesus by remaining I too taciturn and silent okay why this I am unable to say
because my light Jesus does not tell me anything I wrote this only to obey she is moving and getting
a little push towards that if she is to be in the divine will she has to be in agreement with
what the divine will is doing and she's told to imitate Jesus in everything so if he's silent and
taciturn she says oh I must be like that as well her will must agree so february the 20th
1907 it continues with him always in silence in passing and like a flash I spent my days in
bitterness and as though dazed it is as if my whole interior had been struck by a thunderbolt
without being able to move either forward or backward I myself am unable to say what has
happened in my interior I believe it is better to keep silent rather than speak about it well
she's learned that we've got that in the last message haven't we and then this morning he came
for just a little and he told me my daughter one who does not respond to my grace they say
correspond lives like those birds who live by thievery in the same way the soul does nothing but
live by thievery she steals my grace she lives and does not recognize me and she even offends me
and then he disappeared like a flash now the reason why he's talking like this is because the divine
will is in everybody and in everything and there is nothing that we can do that the divine will
doesn't concur with I cannot use my eyes at this moment or my voice or anything unless the divine
will permits it and concurs with it okay and so he's saying that some people who are absolutely
against his will are using all his gifts and graces but not acknowledging him whatever
and they don't acknowledge him as the source or anything so he's saying it's thievery stealing
his stuff okay it's very strong language that it wouldn't be so strong if we didn't know how so
so many people like that so mark the second there's nothing that equals suffering willingly
now the bit that's important there is the willingly he's not saying just nothing that equals suffering
it's the willingly continuing in my usual state and having learned that almost the entire town
was down with the flu and that in other places people were dying I was praying our lord that he
would be kind and despair so many victims and that he would make me suffer to spare them since
nowadays I suffer little or nothing and for he has taken this away from me while I was saying
this he told me in my interior my daughter it was said about me that it was necessary for one man
to die to save the whole people can you at least tell me the gospel which gospel it's only in one
gospel John John chapter 11 verse 50 Caiaphas said it John 11 50 it was a truth but at that time
it was not understood in the same way in all times it is necessary that there be one who suffers
to spare the others these are the victim souls put that at the side these are the victim souls
in order to be accepted one must offer oneself voluntarily okay and you find that St. Therese
offered herself voluntarily Louisa did Padre Pio did know all the others and only for love of God
and their neighbor to suffer himself in order to spare the others so again it's the imitation of
Christ the great victim and the suffering of this one person cannot be equaled by the suffering of
all the others put together because most people suffer unwillingly don't they and so if this person
who doesn't need to suffer decides that for the sake of saving others they would take the other
person's punishment the Lord says that's in a category by itself you'd agree wouldn't you okay
and so and the suffering of this one cannot be equaled by the suffering of all the others put
together there's no value that matches it do you think that the void of your suffering is nothing
yet it is not a complete void and if I suspended you completely where would the people's end up
whoa whoa things won't end here okay so as we said many times before Louisa doesn't seem to look
at the fact that the privation is part of the suffering march the 13th 1907 Louisa praised
Jesus for her mother that she may not go to purgatory after her death it continues almost always the
same way at the most he makes himself seen in silence in these last days when he made himself
seen he would caress and kiss me and since my mother was sick he made me understand that he
would take her so she's told that the mother is going to die or both parents died within a couple
of weeks of each other he made me understand that he would take her I would say to him my lord you
want her and I give her to you as gift before you take her now there's the genius way of responding
to the lord you want her but I give her to you before you take her and I do not want to wait until
you take her without giving her to you before but I want you to recommend I want from you the
recompense for the gift I give you giving me as a reward of you're taking her straight to paradise
which is very unusual in one of these volumes Jesus says that nine out of ten people who die good
people who die go to purgatory that there's practically no one ready to go directly to heaven so
Louisa is asking something very big without letting her touch purgatory at the cost of making me
suffer the purgatory that my her mother would have and blessed Jesus said my daughter let me do
in other words would you let God make the correct decisions okay so returning to pray again
I would say but my sweet love you will have the heart to see my mother suffer in purgatory
she who suffered so much and who cried so much because of me it is the weight of gratitude that
pushes me so does she accept let me do that's all she continues she perseveres who is she like
she's like the woman in Luke 18 verses 1 to 8 she keeps at it and at it and at it and she gets
what she wants it's the weight of gratitude that pushes me that urges me and gives me strength
as for all the other things do whatever you want but in this no I won't give up
you will content me and we'll do what I want
now that's a bit courageous isn't it and he said my beloved do not render yourself too
important unfortunate because we say the woman in Luke 18 was the important widow
you are truly untiring and by being untiring you force me to content you you see you do
get it if you keep persevering however he would not give me a definite answer
I would return to storm him and would cry like a child and praying him and praying him again I
kept offering what he suffered in his passion minute by minute hour by hour applying it to the soul of
my mother that she might be purged purged and embellished and I might obtain my intent
so you're getting a lesson as to how to pray for people you love but he would add
drying my tears but my dear beloved one do not cry you know that I love you can I not content you
see with the continuous offering of my passion as you let nothing escape you of what I suffered
for your mother your soul is inside an immense sea and this sea washes her embellishes her
enriches her in undates her with light when you love to hear that about everyone you loved
and to assure you that I will content you when your mother dies you will be surprised by a fire
and will feel burned oh oh what does that mean you'll get her purgatory yeah you'll be surprised
by a fire in other words she needs it you'll get it I remained content but not certain because he
had not yet told me whether he would take her straight to paradise okay so may the night I think
we'll do this because it follows on from the other one at the death and purgatory of louise's
parents it has been a few months since I wrote and with great repugnance and only to obey I
begin to write again oh what a weight I feel only at the thought that I could say to my beloved
Jesus see how I love you more and how my love grows since for love of you alone I submit myself
to this sacrifice and for as long as it lasts I can also say that I love you more thinking
that I can say to my Jesus that I love him more I feel the strength to make the sacrifice to obey
this is made the ninth 1907 now since I do not remember everything distinctly I will tell you of
the past altogether and confusedly starting from where I left when I was praying that he would take
my mother to paradise so this follows immediately on what we've read without her touching purgatory
then on March the 19th the day dedicated to St Joseph in the morning while I was in my usual
state my mother passed from this life into the sphere of eternity and blessed Jesus allowing me
to see her as he was taking her told me my daughter the creator takes his creature okay
at that moment I felt I was being invested inside and out with a fire so alive that I felt my bowels
my stomach and all the rest burning so she has the fires of purgatory and if I would have something
it would convert into fire and I would be forced to bring it up immediately after I'd swallowed it
this fire consumed me Hebrews 12 29 our god is a consuming fire Hebrews 12 29
this fire consumed me and also kept me alive oh how I understood the devouring fire of purgatory
which while consuming the soul gives her life the fire does the office of food water death and life
but I was happy in that state however since I had only seen that Jesus had taken my mother
but he had not showed me where he had taken her my happiness was not full and from my very sufferings
I would draw concern since those would be the sufferings of my mother if she was in purgatory
and seeing blessed Jesus who in those days has almost never left me now whenever she's suffering
a continuously very deeply like this he stays I would cry and say to him my sweet love tell me
where did you take her I am content that you have taken her from us because you must keep her with
yourself but if you do not have her with yourself this I don't tolerate and I will cry so much
until you content me she would teach you how to pray wouldn't she and he seemed to enjoy my crying
he would embrace me he would sustain me he would dry my tears and he'd say to my daughter do not
fear calm yourself and once you have calmed yourself I will let you see her and you will be very pleased
besides you can have the certainty that I have content to do from the fire that you feel
but I would continue to cry she doesn't let up if she wants to see where her mother is she wants
to see where her mother is and that's that so does she trust him not really no she wants to see the
evidence and I think it's important as well because this experience gives us the courage to truly
believe for me pray for others okay so I would continue to cry especially when I would see him
since I felt in my interior that something was still lacking to the beatitude of my mother
so much so that the people who surrounded me who had come because of the death of my mother in
seeing me cry so much thinking that I was crying because the death of my mother were almost scandalized
thinking that I had moved away from the divine will when more than ever I was swimming in this
sphere of the divine will that's the strange thing about people is that if they know that you're
living a spiritual life they won't allow you to be human and it's terribly important to be human
in front of them the great story about Saint Bernard of Clairvaux who's called the on-ground king of the 12th
century and set up so many monasteries and he was famous all over Europe one of his brothers entered
the monastery with him and they were very close very very close and then some years later his brother
died and Bernard cried so much that he scandalized the whole monastery and they insisted that crying
or no crying he would give the homily at his brother's death and he said he said something like well I
can't say everything he said he said something like you think because I love God that my love
for my brother won't be real he said you think I'm not human and because you think I'm not
human you're not allowing yourselves to become divine you're afraid that you lose your humanity
he says no you become more human you become more complete and he said to them in losing my brother
he said I've lost more than half of me he said and everything inside of me is grieving and he gave
the most incredible homily for the death of his brother I think it's beautiful but the people
looking at Louisa have the same problem if she's in the divine will surely she should just agree
but you can agree but you still have your whole relationship with that person you know and you have
all the the history of that your relationship with that person and you've got all the closeness of
the love and everything you've been through and all the rest of it that's not allowed to express
itself it would be very detrimental and I think it would be very inhuman as well and that just needs
to be said just in case people misunderstand anyone in the divine will but Louisa said I don't
appeal to any human tribunal because of human tribunal because it's false only the divine which
is full of truth and good Jesus was not condemning me on the contrary he would sympathize with me and
in order to sustain me he would come more often almost giving me a reason to cry more because if
you would not come with whom was I to cry to impotrate what I wanted see the people didn't realize that
she was interceding for her mother very intensely the people were right because they judged from
the outside from a human point of view which you can see why put put this down Matthew 7 1 to 5
Matthew 7 1 to 5 that the Lord tells us not to judge we usually get it wrong
so they judged from the outside and then after all since I'm so very bad it's no wonder that
the others would be scandalized with me then after quite a few days as good Jesus came he told me
my daughter be consoled for I want to tell you and show you where your mother is but he didn't do it
until she had done the full purgatory that's incredible isn't it since before and after she
passed away you have suffered continuously that which I earned did and endured for her good in the
course of my life she protects in what I did and enjoys my humanity only the divinity is concealed
from her why is that because the whole church was only at the level of the humanity okay and the
revelation of being in the divinity is only being given through Louisa okay only my divinity is
concealed from her but it will shortly be unveiled to her as well in other words she had a very light
sojourn in someplace that wasn't terrible fire because Louisa took the fire okay but she hadn't
yet seen God in his fullness and the fire you feel and your prayers have served to exempt her
from any other pain of senses which all must have noticed the all notice the most okay I just
want you to notice if you just look at certain words you really don't need an explanation
which all must have because my justice receiving satisfaction from you could not take it from both
okay at that moment I seem to see my mother within an immensity which has no boundaries okay that's
God's presence and in it there were many delights and joys for as many words thought size works
sufferings heartbeats in some for everything that the most holy humanity of Jesus Christ contained
I understood that it is a second paradise for the blessed and in order to enter the paradise of the
divinity one must pass through the paradise of the humanity of Christ okay all must pass through the
the paradise of the humanity of Christ therefore the fact of having touched no other purgatory
had been a most singular privilege for my mother reserved for very few however I understood that
even though she was not amid torments but rather amid delights or happiness was not perfect but
almost halved isn't that incredible because she had yet moved into the divinity so we don't seem to
grasp just how much purification needs to go on to be frightening isn't it
this goes on and on for another couple of pages so I'm going to stop there because the time is up
step okay and we'll just pick it up when we come back because there's there's a lot of thinking
to be done on that isn't there